you and I walk between two wall
that is just a dream that lives here
where do you think the bad manners
hey everybody new Deathstroke Episode
one trailer let's break it down and
there is some news about Roy coming back
yeah Colton Haynes confirmed that he
would be coming back to arrow very soon
implying that it'd be during season six
so I'll explain that in a second but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
presumably if you're watching my arrow
videos you also watch my flash videos so
you know the drill but if you're new I
do giveaway stuff every week that I'll
explain at the end of the video make
sure you click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the
videos but there's so much to talk about
here we got a little more footage in
some more context for what's going on
with Black Canary as well as black siren
I know everybody's still wondering about
vigilante what's going on with the
villains of season six because they've
already confirmed who most of them are
there'll be some more minor villains but
we already know who the really big ones
are and the really cool thing is is the
district is not one of them now he's
never really been a straight-up villain
he's more of an antihero they kind of
vacillates back and forth between bad
and good depending on what the story
needs him to be but I've already done a
couple videos explaining what the
Deathstroke two-part origin story
episodes they're doing or going to be
all about how they're gonna tackle
finding his son Jericho I'll link to
that at the end of this but as far as I
know first half of the season episode 1
episode 5 in episode 6 will be the
Deathstroke episodes and then he might
pop back up once or twice during the
back half of the season and that's also
when I'm expecting Roy to come back and
that'll probably just be for one episode
but if you don't follow Colton Haynes on
a regular basis he was cast as a regular
on another Fox TV show this season that
only shoots 13 episodes meaning that he
does have time to do arrow but probably
not til the back half if you asked you
know like what has he been up to this
whole time why haven't we seen him he
could be back in Bludhaven I know that
raises all kinds of questions about
what's going on with a Titans TV show
because they haven't confirmed whether
that's connected or not connected to the
arrow verse but for the time being
I think they're just gonna try and play
it as easy as possible and just not
refer to that stuff Stephen Amell did
message me you may have seen me tweet
about this just being funny about it the
other day Stephen Amell messaged me on
Twitter the other day to drop a couple
bombs about episode 2 he couldn't give
me any like really big spoilers but he
did say something really special is
going to be happening with episode 2
something comic book related after I
tweeted this at him just saying that
this should be his season 6 avatar just
because it looks really cool not because
I thought that they're gonna do Green
Lantern so maybe there'll be a Green
Lantern named drop during episode 2
we'll see just keep your ears peeled for
big shoutouts but he did make it sound
like it was gonna be a verbal thing it
wouldn't just be like a nametag
situation but if you haven't seen my
other arrow trailer videos we have
confirmed Richard dragon that's gonna
recur during the season and Michael
Emerson so this is the actor that's
gonna be playing Richard dragon and it's
gonna be Ricardo Diaz jr. whose alias is
Richard dragon in the new 52 comics so I
think the idea is to think of it as more
of the new 52 version he had a father
who was a crime boss in Seattle that the
green arrow took down so you know you
killed my father prepare to die so he's
going to be forming an evil team around
him black siren will be part of that so
that's why you see her in the police
station getting ready to set this giant
bomb off you actually see it cut up in
the trailer a little bit weird you see
this big explosion then you see her with
the button so they just make it seem
kind of weird so somebody gets arrested
she walks in busts him out and she'll be
on that villain team for most of the
first half of the season you know second
half of the season anything's up for
grabs it sounds like they're gonna let
her be a straight-up for the first
half of the season which i think is
great I think she's gonna have way more
fun playing that version of Laurel Lance
but no real news about who Michael
Emerson is playing it sounds like you
know because he is like a level above
everybody else that they have on the
show that he might wind up being the big
bad for the season so even though
Richard Dragan is a huge character I'm
still expecting some really big stuff
from Michael Emerson but what about
vigilante everybody always asks about
vigilante they will be unmasked Stephen
Amell used a male pronoun when talking
about him so we know it's a man there
was a few questions about whether or not
it could be a female character but
it sounds like whoever it is it is male
people want it to be Jericho because
he's following in his father's footsteps
Deathstroke and he gets caught in a
kaznian prison during the two-part
Deathstroke episode so Oliver has to go
to kaznia with destro to rescue Jericho
but even though he's gonna be stuck in
an overseas prison that doesn't preclude
him from being vigilante it just depends
on where vigilante shows up in the first
half of the season you guys will be
happy about this
they said that everybody on Team arrow
gets a nemesis this season so you got
some red-hot canary on canary action
obviously Oliver will be going up
against Richard dragon the first half of
the season in Felicity's character will
be dealing mostly with Michael Emerson
early on I think that if he becomes the
big bat then obviously that'll be all of
her stuff the second half the way the
showrunner explained it he said that
when Michael Emerson first comes on
it'll be sort of a felicity storyline
that will eventually involve the rest of
the team so that's why I think that he
could become the big bad of the season
but as for a four-night crossover the
interesting thing that's different about
this year is that they're not
celebrating any anniversaries on arrow
so it'll be more legit plot from the
other shows and they're changing the
order that the shows come in so on that
Monday night it'll be a two-hour block
Supergirl
then arrow then the second night it'll
be another two-hour block with parts 3 &
4 flash and legends of tomorrow so I
know it's a little bit weird with the
arrow schedule this year because they
moved it to Thursday nights
normally arrow episodes will air
Thursday nights at 9:00 p.m. Eastern
Time so you just have to adjust based on
where you live but I'll remind people
about that as we get closer and
obviously you'll just see me post my
episode 1 video so you'd be like ok this
is when it's airing but leave all your
questions in the comments below what I
want to do this year is start doing
flash arrow DC TV Q&A videos again like
I do for Game of Thrones I think it'd be
an easier way to do stuff for all the
shows that I don't necessarily do videos
for so if you have questions about
Supergirl or you have questions about
legends of tomorrow then I normally
wouldn't be able to get to I figure I
could include those in like a big Q&A
video that I do for the DC TV shows so
just let me know if you'd be interested
in something like that it would probably
wind up being like a Friday video
but as of right now they're getting
ready to film the four night crossover
we might get some behind the scenes for
that if we do I'll totally do video for
it
they just tweeted this picture out - of
all the scripts for each of the four
episodes so you can just imagine what's
on those pages
they still haven't revealed who the big
villains going to be but there's still a
lot of good theories that I've seen but
what will happen is is there'll be a new
Marvel and DC coming this weekend I got
some new infinity war to post tomorrow
and some new Rick and Morty
so we'll say congratulations to the
latest flash ring giveaway winner as win
shobun please private message me so I
can get your contact details but while
you wait for everything to post you can
click here for that flash episode one
trailer and you can click here for brand
new Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you